earlier this week we discussed the
acquittal of the entire clan involved in
that Oregon militia occupation and we
also talked about the aggressive and
violent tactics that have been used
against the code access pipeline
protestors I do have some of what i
would consider good news and it's it's
sad that this is even necessary but it
is and it is good news there was a
crowdsourcing campaign organized for the
protesters of the Duke Dakota access
pipeline which we're seeking $5,000 and
the fund has since topped the 1 million
dollar mark and this is several cash
streams which in total have provided
several million dollars in help this
includes legal costs this includes food
and other supplies for the protesters
that are opposing what would be nearly a
1200 mile pipeline and it might also
prolong the ability of the capacity to
continue protesting and this has
attracted thousands of supporters from
all over the country and even outside of
the country as the Standing Rock Sioux
tribe is pursuing a court fight and for
months now opponents of this
multi-billion dollar pipeline have been
camping near the UH where the Missouri
and cannonball rivers come together they
have concerns about the disruption of
cultural artifacts they have concerns
but substantiate it concerns based on
science about the contamination of water
resources of drinking water sources on
the Standing Rock sues nearby
reservation this is really a disaster
and we need to give as much publicity to
this as possible food is being purchased
for the protesters with the money that
has been donated when you go out looking
for five thousand dollars and you raise
over a million this tells you that you
have buy-in at least from a portion of
people around the world and people in
the US and no doubt a legal defense fund
will also be necessary here hundreds of
arrests etcetera etcetera there are uh
many exceptions but by and large when we
look at the criminal justice system in
the United States and the law
enforcement apparatus of the United
States
it's pro-corporate we've talked many
times about unbalanced uh a majority of
court decisions when you strip it down
to is this a pro individual decision or
is this a pro establishment pro status
quo or pro corporate decision on balance
courts and our entire system our system
of policing it is all pro corporate in
the United States and you could argue
that this is because corporations are
just more often right you know
corporations are better informed they
have lawyers and by definition
corporations are going to be an
entanglement switch more likely they're
going to win because they are on the
right side of I don't believe there is
any evidence to suggest that that is
truly the case and when we look at
what's going on with the Dakota access
pipeline and we look at what we know
about the science of these pipelines and
spills and fracking and everything else
that's going on I remain very concerned
that ultimately it's not going to end
well for protesters I'm glad they raise
this money but I do have concerns that
this is just not going to end well and
the pipeline is going to happen and
that's going to be it yeah I mean I just
kind of going along the the corporate
angle that you brought up have we talked
at all about Donald Trump's role in this
not in particularly because I hate to
bring him up in a non Trump story
because it's kind of refreshing to not
talk about him for a moment yeah it's
just interesting because he has
investments in energy transfers partners
and the CEO has donated to his campaign
good man yeah and another interesting
fact here is that that CEO of this
company also donated to Greg Abbott
during 2014 so I'm just starting to kind
of think about how Donald Trump doesn't
really have a good handle or grasp on
energy in general yet he's really close
all these fossil fuel tycoons and that
worries me yeah i mean if if if you
weren't already concerned enough that a
Donald Trump presidency is not
necessarily going to be a win for
alternative energy and and reducing our
dependence on dirty fossil fuels
etcetera the connections that rachel is
pointing out would certainly make me
more concerned and the thing that's most
frustrating to me is when I read about
well what are the pros of this pipeline
and one of them is well will we
would be less dependent on foreign oil
yet to some degree that's true but we
would still be dependent on oil the
price of which doesn't exist in a vacuum
in the United States it is impacted by
political decisions around the world is
it is impacted by supply decisions and
disruptions in countries in the Middle
East and around the world and I just
don't buy Pat when the pro pipeline
people say hey it'll just be better for
us because we'll get off of foreign oil
it's sort of ignoring that we could be
off of fossil fuels all together if we
made a commitment to doing that in this
issue really hasn't been too much up to
the public to debate too because the
media is largely ignoring it so it's
impressive that this group is able to
raise five thousand dollar or a million
dollars far past their goal of five
thousand yet we've seen these sort of
crowdfunding campaigns just take off and
this is one of them though I will
mention that sometimes when a
crowdfunding campaign raises way more
money than they intended to there isn't
always a use for that money uh and and
sometimes money ends up being squandered
but it does seem here like the financial
resources will actually be put to good
use